c'est le point final d'un projet à 250
millions d'euros débuté en 2010 la
rénovation du centre commercial parly ii
implantée aux chaînés depuis 1969 et
dans sa dernière phase
180 ouvriers travaillent actuellement
sur une liaison de 10 mille mètres
carrés qui permettra une circulation
boucle dans le centre et d'accueillir
des magasins supplémentaires derrière
nous il y aura un grand rectangle qui
accueillera sur deux niveaux l'extension
du monoprix est aussi une cellule pour
accueillir la poissonnerie et derrière
dans l'angle la partie longue duel se
trouvera donc cette connexion entre deux
partis du centre avec ses 15 ans scènes
supplémentaires
le lifting s'opère également à
l'extérieur du centre commercial les
façades extérieures construite au siècle
dernier sont actuellement en cours de
restauration
les façades ont bien commencé un vous
aurez un aperçu au niveau de la façade
du bhv c'est à la fois un alliance des
motifs historiques depardieu qu'on
appelle les moucharabiehs il y a aussi
des plaques de mbk en céramique sur les
façades principales et enfin sur
certains angles un habillage en pierre
de vals grise bleue pour habiller les
façades notamment côté voie publique
avec ces travaux la structure qui attire
déjà 12 millions de visiteurs par an
espère en accueillir 3 millions de plus
à l'horizon 2018 redonné en fait à paris
deux son rayonnement régional
et à les capter une clientèle alors de
paris 16ème en passant par saint germain
en laye jouy en josas montfort l'amaury
pas à pas une concurrence notamment
renforcé avec un beau grenelle 1 vélizy
un plaisir à saint germain en laye donc
voilà fort de cette rénovation des
parties communes des parties extérieures
des façades et cette offre
supplémentaire de 15 en scène
supplémentaire
on est vraiment un mais pour les
prochaines décennies l'inauguration
officielle est programmée pour la fin
novembre parly 2 proposera à partir de
cette date 117 mille mètres carrés de
surfaces commerciales et plus de 200
magasins à deux ans de fêter ses 50 ans